[Musique]
c'est une faire faire un bébé c'est vrai
il tend il te dit ans
[Musique]
du jamais vu depuis longtemps et 1 et ne
pique tout japonais
il ya un très joli sourit aussi très
belle voix le tournoi comme un pétale
novelli
[Musique]
pourquoi on souhaite la fête à toutes
les mamans tous les ans j'aime bien nous
a fait naître notamment chez onex ge
puis celle nous console et nous fait tpc
[Musique]
quand on sent qu'on a brassé on a les
mains moites ont des autoroutes coeur
qui bat
bref c'est le truc tout bête on pense qu
ait cassé quand même où celle que même
au nom fait des rêves on a fait des
cauchemars où le plan on peut plus on
sait plus quoi faire
enfin on peut aimer quelqu'un insiste
que ce soit réciproque donc on essaye de
pas trop de patrons de montrer
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand on est
amoureuse bah je sais pas on est souvent
en va aussi m'aider qu'on se retrouve ça
c'est c'est un peu comme s'il y avait
personne
[Musique]
paris
m
me
paris
[Musique]